comme chez bmt aura du retard du fait
arrêter par la police non hasard que
j'étais en voiture et la vie de descend
donc évidemment genre donc là vous des
cds sans la vitre ouais je fais ce que
je t'ai souvent évidemment j'enlève mes
lunettes comme superman
zelaya attendait sa cabine tiens le
connard bon je vois qu'à pas beaucoup
d'effet et du coup je rajoute cette
phrase je dis pardon je ferai un petit
peu la voie des bus est très en retard
je vais faire ma prestation de co
animateur à tpm et co-animateur et
c'était une femme le regarde et qui me
dit pardon je sais pas qui vous êtes et
je me suis dit je suis tombé sur la flic
en europe qui me connaît pas bagdad
allez vous fait quoi
bref à lire tournée n'était pas bête je
le ferai pas ses fans un jeu c'est la
cata pas de couilles quand même
commencer par ça n'est pas la tiba et
quand c'est devant
ouais alors il ya trois mots de trous
déjà vous laisser rentrer et à moi de
parler comme ça laisse entrer parce que
vous vous ni se veut comme ça mais bien
garder son chien
il y aura deux vendredi vers 10h 18h à
nous c'est très simple c'est quand tu
veux ou tu veux
[Applaudissements]
il
j'ai un copain il ya une meuf à lui
renvoyer ces paroles genre boîte de you
mean qui parlait pas anglais il a fait
google translate pendant toute la nuit
c'est le seul pour qui ce qui très
bavard toi on fera un combat en début
d'émission attention ratatat avait pris
des 200 kw moi donc tu as un cours comme
a dit franco va se calmer tu me laisse
le temps de tenir des cours auxquels
vous avez dit cochon en quelques courts
et du bassin ou d'avion moi je vous sais
pas quand je veux où je veux c'est quand
vous voulez vous voulez en fait c'est ce
qu'on fera
mais te rends compte que si je gagne ça
veut dire que pour l'année prochaine tu
vas prendre un tout petit peu à fermer
ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien je vais m'en occuper dès
demain ouais hein lannoy production dans
ces cas-là you're a rich qui me suit
dégâts sur un pool moi c'est encore un
peu tôt
[Applaudissements]
sa maman
[Musique]
hu
[Applaudissements]
j'aime l'odeur de ta peau on a remis la
douceur de ton corps
j'aime tes cheveux ouais j'aime quand tu
parles
ouais quand tu souris ouais et nerfs
ouais t'es défauts sont mes calibré
comme quand je te vire oui mais ça va
être un point mais là un petit peu
scientifique et c'est vrai quand on
meurt la première chose qui a c'est que
le corps se déshydrate
il ya plus d'eau la peau devient
complètement différente on ne reconnaît
même plus un visage là on voit bien ce
visage qui n'est pas du tout déshydraté
la personne et non absolument arrêter
vous avez été médecin légiste
j'ai juste fait ce que vous n'avez pas
fait mon chéri des études
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis
non
c'est
je voulais je suis alors deux minutes je
suis tentée en tête
qu'est-ce qui se passe allez faire un
coup de pression quoi venez faire un
coup de pression il vous reste et fait
montre alors c'est peut-être un truc que
j'ai apprécié un diamant ça je te
montrer mais là bien là j'ai fait de la
télé plus facile à chanter bien
vraiment le faire sur moi na na waie tel
pas j'ai montré à tous tout bête
chauffée à ok mais fait pas mal c'est
rien mais ça a pris là en ce moment dans
mes cours est d'accord il ya un mois de
sa peine à ew com comment magique tu es
prêt c'est un truc tout bête tu fais ça
tu amènes la personne d'un côté et du
cou
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
à
et matthieu delormeau et un excellent
producteur animateur chez très bon stage
est une excellente saison aussi on n'en
parle pas mais ça tout petit peu la
voilure
parce que la star c'est lui mais
à